we're all used to the traditional
operators like addition and subtraction
and multiplication and division and
we've seen there's multiple ways to
represent this but what we're going to
do in this video is is a little bit of
is a little fun we're actually going to
define our own operators and what's neat
about this is it kind of shows how broad
mathematics can be and in a more
practical sense it's actually something
that you might see on some standardized
tests and the reason why they do that is
so that you can appreciate that these
aren't the only operators out there plus
exponentiation all those that in
mathematics you can define a whole new
set of operators so let's just do that
so let me just define
x
diamond
x diamond y and i'm going to define that
as i'm just going to find that as 5 x
minus y
so you could view this as kind of
defining it a function but we're
defining it using an operator so if i
have x diamond y
by definition we have defined this
operator that means that's going to be
equal to 5x minus y
so given that definition what would
what would
diamond
11 be
well you just go to the definition 7
diamond 11
for instead of an x we have a 7 so it's
going to be 5 times 7 so let me do it 5
times 7
minus instead of a y we have an 11. so
one way to think about it is every in
our definition every place you saw in x
you can replace with the seven every
place you saw y you're replaced with
eleven so you have minus eleven over
here let me make the num so this is the
seven
this seven is this seven
and this 11
this 11 is this 11 right over here and
then we just evaluate that so 5 times 7
is 35 so this is equal to 35
minus 11 which is equal to 24. so 7 star
or not this is the star 7 diamond 11 is
equal to 24. we can define other things
we can define something crazy like let
me define
a
well i mentioned a star let me use a
star a star
a let me write this way a star
b
let's say that that is the same thing as
i don't know a
over
a plus b
and so same idea what would
what would
what would 5 star
5 star 6 be
well you go back to the definition by
definition every place where you see the
a you would now replace with the five
every time you saw the b you would now
replace with the six so this is going to
be equal to
five
over
five plus six a plus b
a is five b is six over five plus six so
this would be five elevenths
five elevens and then you can compound
them and we haven't defined any order of
operations for these particular
operations that we've just defined so
we're gonna be careful to use
parentheses when we do when we when we
put some of these together but you could
do something like something interesting
like negative 1
star diamond negative 1 diamond
0 star
0 star 5. and once again we just focus
on parentheses because that's the only
thing that's telling us what to start on
first because we haven't we haven't
figured out we haven't defined whether
diamond takes precedence over star star
takes precedence over diamonds the way
that we have that saying that hey you do
multiplication before you do addition we
haven't defined it for those operations
but that's what the parentheses helps us
do
so we want to evaluate this parentheses
first 0 star 5 that is 0
because so now this you could view this
as 0 as the a and the 5 as the b so it's
going to be 0
over 0 plus 5
over 0 plus 5 which is just going to be
zero so this over here is zero or five
or just goes to zero so this whole
expression simplifies to negative one
diamond this diamond right over here
diamond zero and now we go to the
definition of the diamond operator well
that's five times the first the first
number in our operator the first the
first term that we're giving the
operator i guess you could think of it
that way
so five times that so it'll be five
times
negative one x is negative one minus y
well y here is the zero
minus zero so five times negative one
five times negative one is negative five
and you will see and and the idea here
is just to make you feel comfortable
defining new operators like this and not
being daunted if all of a sudden you see
a diamond and they're defying the
diamond for you and you're like wait i
never saw a diamond and the reason
they're actually defining it for you so
you shouldn't say i never saw a diamond
you'll say oh well they've defined a
diamond for me this is how i use that
operator and sometimes you'll see even
wackier things you'll see things like
you'll see things like
let me draw so they'll define
so this is you know i don't know if you
would even consider this an operator but
you'll see you'll see something like
this that by definition if someone
writes a symbol like this and they put
an
a b
c let me write it this way a
b
c d they'll say this is the same thing
as a d
minus b
all of that over c and once again this
is just a definition they have this
weird symbolic way of representing these
variables and all this but they're just
they're defining how do you evaluate
this crazy expression and so if you if
someone were to give you were to say
evaluate this diamond
evaluate let me evaluate the diamond
so evaluate the diamond
where in my little sections of the
diamond i have a negative one a five a
three and a two we would just use the
definition of how to evaluate this
diamond and we'd say okay every time we
see an a that is going to be negative
one so we have a negative 1
times
every n times d well d is whatever's in
the bottom right section of this diamond
or this kite so d is going to be 2 let
me write this way this is a
this is b
this is c
and this is d
so it's going to be negative one times
two
minus b
well b is five
minus five all of that over c which is
three so this is going to be equal to
negative 2 minus 5. so that is negative
negative 7 over 3. and you could go
crazy like this and it might be a fun
thing actually if you have some spare
time define your own operators and see
how creative you can get with those
operators